next question this is from at Allen
Alvarado on Twitter
Tiger belly what is one thing you would
change with time travel Oh
in the past your past it could even be a
personal thing so don't have to be like
you know stop the Holocaust but just in
your own life that personal to you okay
one can be a time the butterfly effect
so one tiny thing
George anything that you didn't tell us
a story by Brad Pitt I don't know
wouldn't broken up with one girl that's
a boring one though why lately George 37
getting hand jobs I'm back in it man to
completion complete completion remember
it wit in your eye yeah that's the one
thing he never got in his own eye you
nodded and squirted in your own eye yeah
it took forever cuz this girl was not
like it was like very tentative yeah so
then it was so built up by the time it
came yeah it was just like a rocket
right in my own [ __ ] eye I was
blinking the whole time I was kind of
happy but I was like uh yeah yeah he
disgusting gross you heathen so if he's
already pink dick with pinkeye what does
that make him just pink all over ya
pinkest i pink her i you you seem like
you have chunky come oh I know you do I
know I have very chunky come it's like
oatmeal hey homie I get I get both what
the sides doesn't matter it doesn't
matter now
good that was sick at one point now I
came up black honestly that that
question really threw me for a loop
because of the fact that I believe that
I don't wouldn't change anything about
my life right now and I believe that if
I change anything in the past it could
indirectly affect my life
sure right so yeah yeah like even the
little bit of a you know of a change
especially gigantic historical events
would change my life yeah there there
been no changes everything that's true I
think some of the regrets I have
always like what I say on this podcast
cuz I always think that it's just the
four of us and I often forget there are
a lot of people listening
so I say some dumb [ __ ] a lot and I'll
be the first to admit that sometimes
when I listen back I cringe and I'm like
wolf kalila you didn't that did not come
out how like you intended
my other regret is not what specific
thing do you have a specific thing were
you thinking of you um one of it was I
like I talked about defending the
[ __ ] Philippine president that makes
me cry because it's like come on like
you just wanted to oppose you know also
I think I'm not even gonna say it cuz it
makes me say now my my butt clenched
like when we got into that whole red
band cape quigley thing I wish that
whole thing disappeared I wish that we
never even like there's another that's
one thing we went on the one you know we
didn't go high like we we we we got
petty it was petty and it was stupid and
and yeah and I wish I want Agana Joey
Diaz his podcast and talk about John
Caporal oh wow that caused the whole
storm yeah him and I are not no longer
friends
and it's weird he may never get fixed
and you know I shouldn't have done that
I should have just shut my mouth I know
that he did these things in the past but
I had to let it go at the time and it's
like it was just something that I
shouldn't have said because you know at
the end of the day he's a very good
comic and um you know he's not the
nicest guy in the world but still I was
kind of friends with him you know we
would say talk to each other and stuff I
just just regret that whole episode
really to be honest with you yeah you
see him yelling at me and getting that
screaming fight that we had yeah yeah I
didn't like it you know I you know you
know that's another thing is that
getting into wars with comics in general
which is I'm always in the middle of
them mm-hmm I've just done with that
yeah that feeling is not something that
I ever want to feel even that whole
thing with with us talking about like
Charlie and whatnot yeah you know that
had repercussions and
you know I didn't I didn't go unscathed
and he wanted to you know retaliate in
his own way and I accept it but at the
same time it's it's unsettling you know
it's unsettling and it doesn't make you
feel good it doesn't make your day go
well and you know it's like a lot of
things I've learned this year is that it
doesn't always have to be said
especially when it's like personal stuff
really really personal stuff we don't
need to say it there are a ton of other
things that we can talk about we can
share a few things about our lives like
in the past but if it's happening today
maybe we should sit on it a little
longer before we you know maybe let it
marinate a little longer let the
situation marinate before we talk about
it cuz friendships could end people
could get hurt
and it's just not a good place to be
yeah the whole thing was um it was
terrible it's it's terrible and I I
mostly feel just confused about hold
rested in the moment and I've been
ignoring it and avoiding it to be able
to do because I haven't talked to him oh
there was an aftermath no I haven't
talked to mom he thought that it would
make him feel better to unleash all his
anger towards me I think that he truly
believes that somehow I've manipulated
Bobby to go against him and it's like
the only thing I've manipulated Bobby to
do is to write you checks that's the
only manipulation I've done when Bobby
was reluctant to help the only thing
I've ever said to bad Bobby is don't
leave your friend hanging so for the
fact that he wants to troll on Instagram
and say all these things about me is
really unsettling cuz it's like dude I
was always on your side I came up with a
hashtag Charlie is a good guy
I made stickers of his face I really
wanted to see what we could do with him
you know cuz he was his best friend
and it makes me really sad that all of a
sudden I became enemy number one to him
when I always felt like in my heart I
him to be a part of our family I wanted
him to be our ally I wanted I wanted to
be his ally and I don't know it just
makes me sad all together but that's
another regret that I guess is just
talking about it at all yeah at all he
didn't you know
[Music]